et me suis retrouvée ici à Singapour
cinq semaines plus tard,
moins affectée par le décalage horaire que je ne le suis maintenant.
Et ce fut une révélation.
Nous avons traversé cinq mers,
deux océans, neuf ports,
et j'ai appris beaucoup de choses sur le transport maritime.
L'une des premières choses qui m'a surprise
lorsque je suis arrivée à bord du Kendal
a été le nombre de personnes.
J'ai des amis de la marine
qui me disent qu'ils naviguent avec 1 000 marins à la fois,
mais sur le Kendal il n'y avait que 21 membres d'équipage.
C'est parce que l'industrie maritime est très efficace.
La conteneurisation l'a rendue très efficace.
Les navires sont automatisés maintenant.
Ils peuvent fonctionner avec de petites équipes.
Mais concrètement, cela signifie aussi,
d'après le capitaine que j'ai rencontré,
que le marin moyen que l'on trouve
sur un navire porte-conteneur, est soit fatigué ou épuisé.
Parce que le rythme de la navigation moderne
est tout à fait impitoyable avec ce qu'on appelle
l'élément humain de l'industrie maritime,
une phrase étrange dont on ne semble pas se rendre compte,
et qui donne une impression inhumaine.